29 juillet draft nba 2021 le premier
choix sera pour les detroit pistons on
s'en rapproche on sera chez la force
team en live oui vous êtes chez
envergure si vous n'aviez pas vu en
attendant on vous prépare à cette draft
en attendant le 29 juillet avec une
question dans ce podcast quel joueur
dans cette pub et peuvent être des
initiateurs des porteurs de ballon bref
des gens qui ont des responsabilités en
nba à travers cette question il y en a
mille autres des réponses qui vont avec
et qui vont nous aider à classer les
joueurs puisque c'est ça aussi
l'important plus la draft approche plus
on essaye d'être précis dans le
classement qu'on a en tête
voilà c'est le programme de cet épisode
avec manu avec alan avec ben et ce qu'on
donne encore les numéros d'épisodes lui
c'est le 23 saisons 4 bienvenue sur
envergure bienvenue dans le futur
[Musique]
l'homme qui avait gardé la foi en jayden
mac daniels et qui avait raison manuela
aulas camarades aulas comment vas tu as
la fatigue mais ça marche on se
rapproche du grand jour l'excitation un
peu comme dans quinze jours on
enregistre officiellement le 14 juillet
bonne fête nationale à tous à zéro heure
6 c'est pour ça que tu dis la fatigue
parce que voilà on est dédié à cette
draft 2021 eux aussi le son ils sont
avant gardiste et nico les a surnommés
les draft punk à l'année ben ça va les
gars salut tout le monde
l'ex gendre incroyable incroyable sur
non vous n'avez pas de casque mais mais
ça va parler prospère aujourd'hui donc
plein de joueurs on vous conseille avant
de commencer on vous conseille si vous
le pouvez d'écouté en regardant notre
site
comme ça vous avez sous les yeux les
profils de ses joueurs les stats les
points forts et les points faibles et
mensurations vous avez un petit peu le
l'image qui se fait en plus du son
la question aujourd'hui c'est donc qui
peut porter la balle en billets dans
cette draft ça paraît un peu con j'en
suis conscient
et d'ailleurs les chroniqueurs sont un
peu perdus mais en fait non pourquoi
cette question je vous donne juste
l'exemple de la drave 2018
aujourd'hui trois ans après ils sont en
train de signer des extensions de
contrat qui est porteur de ballon numéro
un ou numéro 2 on adopte shit shanghai
hong hong à gi joe alexander un peu
colline sexton mais ce qu'il est
vraiment premier porteur de ballon pas
vraiment un petit peu kevin huard terre
deuxième porteur de ballon ahronot
hallyday quand ils jouent l'oni walker
devan t g challenge bronson
si on veut pousser cheikh milton est
vraiment super séquence bref ça fait une
dizaine sur 60 drafté quand même donc ça
fait pas beaucoup ça veut pas dire que
les autres qui sont de rester pour
d'autres rôles n'ont pas d'impact mais
ça nous permet de définir une catégorie
plutôt que de prendre un poste c'est
beaucoup plus simple que dire un meneur
un arrière un ailier puisqu'il ya moins
de différences en fait dans ce qu'on va
leur demander
au niveau supérieur et ça sera plus
facile de les classer puisqu'on aura
plus ou moins on va retrouver des
caractéristiques communes chez ses
joueurs
voilà l'explication premier groupe on va
les classer par groupes de niveau ces
joueurs de la draft 2000 21 premiers
groupes de niveau je commençais par ben
donc on dit premier tiers quand on est
en angleterre ben le premier groupe de
niveau est acquis le don gellé bolender
de cette draft
je crois qu'à terme d'abord le premier à
pâtir uniquement à critérium qui ont un
niveau ou de d'athlétisme de de force de
créativité qui permet massy qui parle de
lui-même la vie vraiment touché à la son
niveau l'os pour soi qui est quelqu'un
de gamme fait vraiment l'unanimité comme
premier pays sedanais ce premier tiers
il va nous servir en fait à définir les
qualités d'un boyfriend puisque le
portrait de kate koenig gamme en fait on
l'a déjà fait on l'a déjà fait dans son
podcast dans le podcast qui lui est
dédié bardon et vous avez juste à aller
sur notre site pour le retrouver
manu quelle qualité que tu h et kyle
cunningham est ce que pour toi c'est
pareil d'abord est-ce qu'il est tout
seul dans son chapeau 1
si on parle d'initiation pur moi je
rajoute ne choquerait pas de rajouter
charles cooper dans ce chapeau 1
mais vraiment d'initiation purge parle
pas en terme de niveau ça veut dire quoi
pour toi du coup ils initiation ça veut
dire vision ça veut dire création pour
pour les autres surtout visualisation de
lait des espaces voilà surtout ça
surtout dans la création
j'ai vu ben qui a allumé son micro et
qu'ils arrêtent un qui voulait réagir
bétail parce que je me suis tout fait
ouais vous dire on en parlera peut-être
plus tard pour charef cooper moi je ne
crois pas vraiment comme initiateur
numéro un billet pour des causes qui
convient à voir avec sa vision du golfe
mais je comprends la logique de manu
hockey alan le premier chapeau des
bolender calé contre je ne paye tout
seul pour quelle raison enfin non pas
pour quelles raisons pardon quelles
qualités pour toi un initiateur doit
avoir pour être tout en haut du
classement des initiateurs de sa draft
trois choses principalement d'avoir la
capacité à jouer du piano
aulas autre intensité en tant que
nouveau porteur de balle la capacité
ensuite à pouvoir tirer en sortie de
dribble
ce que n'a pas puisque non en fait
qu'elle et ses seuls qui pour moi les
trois qualités de vivacité et des
certains ont l'une certains en ont deux
mais aucun aucun un trône à l'e3 sauf
qu'à est donc la peur restait à jouer du
pick and roll la capacité à sortir en
sortie de dribble et la capacité à
pouvoir faire remettre toutes les passes
possible que ce soit le mans droite -
gauche pour son intérieur qui va au
cirque pour son intérieur qui s'écartent
pour ce les shooteurs dans les coins
pour les shooteurs à 41 d'exploiter le
décalage qu'il crée exactement à pouvoir
encore comprendre quoi faire
grâce au fait d'être en capacité
d'initier la taxe est bien d'initier des
attaques mais qui est une gamme nuit qui
comprend ce que ça enclenche le fait que
les défenses et peur de son initiation
d'attac et donc il arrive à pouvoir
faire quoi quasiment tout n'est ce pas
ça rende pas d'en jouer le pick-and-roll
sait mais en fait jouer le piano c'est
plus aussi pour aller au cercle après
jour les enjeux intermédiaires pour
poulin pas à mi-distance pouvoir jouer
sur tout ce qui est flotteurs runner
lieners aller au cercle
bien sûr ça rentre dans le pick and roll
c'est une des deux choses principales
avec le tira mais j'ai bien essayé voulu
un peu m pick'n'roll pour soi même et
pick'n'roll pour les autres en gros ok
donc et créer une création pour soi-même
création
pour les autres les deux qualités
principales donc il faut du tir alors
manu va peut-être me répondent pas
nécessairement puisqu'il a mis à shariff
pour toi manu s'était plus le la
création pour les autres ouais c'est sûr
tout est là bas la création la visual
visualisation de l'espace du terrain le
fait que voilà je prends une décision qu
est ce que ça importe pour le reste de
mon attaque
est-ce que tu as un exemple de personnes
en nba qui serait un gros porteur de
ballon et qui qui serait pas qu'ils
seraient moins un scoreur pour lui même
que pour les autres
chris paul - je les enjoins mouais mais
vraiment grille dribble jamais presque
en fait bah ils amènent la balle mais il
n'ya pas curé à côté ça marche jamais
sacré bon le panier un kyle cunningham
allait peut-être sharif cooper on va
simplement parler rapidement puisque je
crois qu'on n'a pas fait podcast sur lui
des bêtises
manu sharif cooper c'est qui en quelques
en quelques mots présentement prospère
alors c'est un petit garçon qui joue à
auburn donc donc cahuet les petites
embrouilles dont il a bien joué que 14
matches froid de tête voit même mois
mahmoud quelque chose comme ça fait sens
qu aucune réponse je sais plus mais oui
oui il a très peu joué ici un meneur
donc et pas forcément petit finalement
que ce qu'on a vu qu'il est ému la
démesure rester assez gros combat mais
en fait c'était une erreur
il fait bien un mètre 80 88 entre 85 et
4 accords mais c'est un fort passeur moi
j'aime beaucoup sa capacité à créer pour
les autres un peu il a pas encore cette
capacité à créer pour lui mais vraiment
pour les autres il est vraiment
intéressant
il aime beaucoup le shooter même s'il
est une mécanique un peu à peu un peu
étonnante mais voilà c'est surtout un
créateur pour pour les autres cas un peu
ce coureur aussi voilà un joueur un peu
un peu fou fou mais que moi
personnellement même bien c'était assez
solide cette saison il faut dire
20 points 12 matches joués donc enfin 28
la changer là il a changé les visages à
l'odeur non plus des cerises et c'est ça
ça surtout l' influence sur l'équipe
mais bon 20 points 8 passes
alors seulement 39% de réussite aux tirs
mais voilà 20 points 8 passes et 4
balles perdues donc un ratio de deux
passes décisives pour un ballon perdu
c'est pas mal du tout pour surtout pour
un meneur freshman qu'ils avaient de
fortes responsabilités puisque avait 33
% de taux d'utilisation du ballon lusage
wright comme on dis donc toi tu le mets
dans ton tiers 1 est ce qu'il est dans
le tiers deux des autres est ce qu'il
est dans le groupe de niveau 2 de ben et
alan oui oui chez alan et ben les gars
de charlotte cooper c'est je comprends
un concert que je comprends l'idée je
comprends la projection mais j'arrive
quoi il croit il a menti à 3
personnellement mais si tu crois pas ils
peuvent même pas une tente on tire trop
alors parce que si la fois là bas il
fait quoi
justement moi je ne rêve pas ah voilà
donc n'a pas de ton qui a même plus bas
alors de nous des arguments ben bongo
doit parler de problèmes
le problème est que je vois ce que vous
voyez en chaleur cooper je vois la
vitesse je vois la créativité je vois la
capa l'explosivité la capacité de battre
son homme à un contrôle absolument fumée
la compétition le contrôle pour se
rendre aux familles mais
physiquement parlant j'ai beaucoup de
difficulté à croire qu'il va être
capable de créer comme ça on lit
vraiment sortir son tir mashaal beaucoup
spécialement à trois points je pense
avait regardé mais à trois points
il manque tellement de force
physiquement qui vole qui se penchent
qui se penche pour donner une espèce de
2 comme on appelait ça que l'effet
commune de la force supplémentaire
ouais ouais mais c'est quoi l'on larmes
la catapulte qui catapulte sont très
exactement puis ça j'aime pas c'est
surtout ça c'est la preuve que ça lui
prend beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
gymnastes beaucoup beaucoup de force
je sais pas si le le la capacité
physique de mettre tous muscles et ici
le jour pour être capable de vous
contacter j'ai beaucoup de difficulté à
croire qu'il va s'habituer à niveau tous
évolutionnaire que l'ennemi
je suis d'accord qu'à 1 donc pour toi
c'est ce que tu sais ce que disait manu
en fait quand il le décret pour toi il
va pas être capable de scorer pour lui
même
j'ai beaucoup de difficulté à voir
comment il va scorer par lui-même et les
défenses et lui coller au cul les gars
bon les gars vont lui coller aux
pantalons vont lui la ville et pantalon
devant lui remettre sur le dos appel
j'ai beaucoup de difficulté à voir
je comprends je veux aimer sherry cooper
d'acs qui a battu mardi
alors est-ce qu'on a des
contre-arguments dents du côté de la
défense
effectivement il a il ajouté à moins de
50% au cercle pour donner de l'eau à son
moulin 46 sur 93 complément de 1 50% au
cercle à l'année ce que tu es d'accord
avec ben oui tous les points qui sont
avancées par ben sont réels mais en même
temps on arrive souvent à des certains
moments d'une draft où il y en a
plusieurs écoles et l'école de l'école
d'aller chercher sur le talent brut
la cavale des choses qui sont assez
unique dans une cuve est une des
capacités qui sont plus rares que
d'autres ben moi ça m'intéresse toujours
plus en fait que d'aller draf et
d'autres profils donc ça peut faire sur
côté certains profils mais c'est un peu
quelque chose qui m'intéresse est en
réalité sharif cooper en termes de pelé
making balle en main il ya ya que
quelques nigam et peut-être georges didi
par moments qui sont plus plus élaboré
que lui mais en réalité sur caisse en
transition sur demi terrain en pick and
roll il l'a il invente des passes en
fait ils inventent des angles de passes
main droite main gauche laroui le
système d'auburn était pas mal pour lui
franchement dans les systèmes les plus
c'est intéressant il ya des fruits ndi
là où le plus méritant mais bon c'était
pas mes gars talentueux non plus il y
avait pas mal de tirs ouverts qui
rentrait pas dans mes mais non en fait
je pense qu'au minimum ça sera menée
backup en fait au minium ça peut être un
meneur backup qui va ta porte qui va
rester sur le terrain parce qu'il va
t'apporter dupes les making si il tire
pas eh bien il faut y mettre quatre
tireurs à côté et en nba aujourd'hui ça
peut se faire plus facilement que dans
d'autres époques on va dire
et comme comme tu l'as à mon sens son
article aussi de scouting report
alex de tir we stand pour stage à trois
premiers pas bon mais c'est un peu comme
bic et boston
quand tu commences mal sur un petit
échantillon ça prend des revers le
battait chiffres alors qu'en réalité je
pense que c'est un meilleur shooteur
qu'il l'est et il l'a fait pour son pour
sage au lancer-franc essayé pourcentage
dans les les années passées comme
laisser penser ça donc moi c'est un
risque que je prends parce qu'en terme
de plémet king il est juste trop fort
pour que je sorte de mon top 10 tout
simplement moi je vais juste dire ben
ton idée de la catapulte et est un très
bon argument sauf qu'il est assez facile
à contourner en dix ans bah en fait il a
juste a ajouté de la force puisque
justement en high school
c'est ça veut pas dire qu'il est
maladroit en fait toi tu dis juste
qu'ils manquent de force tu dis pas
qu'il est maladroit
oui c'est un bon sens et ce que je dis
aussi c'est que là avec son son seul son
format très petit jeu c'est pas ajouter
à ses débuts j'étais assez de force pour
se rendre là où il a besoin il a
[Musique]
visiblement il a beaucoup progressé en
catch and shoot ce que j'ai lu jury
athletics pas moi qui le dit c'est des
gens qui ont assisté à son procès il
travaille beaucoup et etc et il a une
vraiment pas nier qu'il a une vraiment
puisque en high school i
vous pouvez ajouter en sortie de dribble
regarder les matchs de lycée pour le
scouting n'importe quoi ajouté en sortie
brigue un trois points mais la ligne est
plus proche manu tu me confirme la ligne
est plus proche school quincy ouais
silence
il ay sous silence c'est l'ancien fiba
6,25 donc voir un peu plus proche choix
que des fois ça touche vraiment le début
de la raquette
ouais ouais ouais d'accord la tête de
raquette
est ce que tu as des choses à ajouter
sur lui manu était plutôt de quelle
école quand il s'agit de descendre dans
la draft puisque là en fait on est
descendu juste d'un étage et on a déjà
des débats sur est ce que finalement il
est dans le panier de où le panier droit
moi je pense que c'est typiquement un
joueur qui va être meilleur en nba je
sais pas pourquoi c'est un joueur auquel
je crois beaucoup
notamment parce que comme disait à la
nuit il y en termes de passe
c'est juste incroyable ce qu'il sait
faire quoi donc je n'ai pas trop
d'inquiétude à le voir même s'il a la
taille peut-être est un petit point à un
point fait mais eux javel et j'avais la
même sur la tête j'étais un peu réservé
sur sûr très yang et finalement on voit
que c'est un gars qui tend la nba
moderne arrive totalement à survivre
même si très yang c'est qu'on voit là
c'est sera déjà prédit m ouais voilà
mais il y avait cette même capacité à
créer pour les autres aussi à trouver
des jolies passes donc moi je suis pas
trop inquiet là dessus je trouve et le
88 % aux lancers francs comme les héros
l'anoci c'est que wilko à 3 83 ou alors
j'ai pu lire mais ça montre qu'il ya il
a un potentiel a minima après je pense
que ça va prendre un peu de temps sur
ceux comme la ligne à 3 points en nba
c'est quand même sur fos que la coquille
et donc je pense que ça on dirait on se
trouve comme on dit tout le temps
pendant quatre ans oui oui mon lave mais
c'est intéressant parce que du coup alan
est ce que tu penses pas que
le fait que ça va lui prendre du temps
parce que ça c'est assez évident que ça
va lui prendre du temps est ce qu'une
franchise va prendre ce temps en fait
surtout chez les arrières où on se rende
compte que bas
si tu joues pas les 2/3 promis de
premières années on m'a vite de côté et
puis on passe à autre chose quoi je
pense que ça va prendre moins de temps
qu on pourrait le penser en réalité ça
aurait pris du temps il ya 20 ans il ya
15 ans et on regarde beaucoup plus
longtemps
c'était dur pour les meneurs pour les
pauvres des balles de survivre s'ils
arrivent en nba
maintenant c'est les intérieurs qui
morfle et qui peuvent pas vraiment joué
je trouve peser dans les débuts d'année
en réalité tu me tues mais charef cooper
avec un contre eux des bancs nba avec
des bons joueurs à côté des bons joueurs
il faut dire même temps que toutes les
équipes qui travaillent ont des bons
joueurs je pense que ça pourrait oui ça
s'apprend et ça peut prendre du temps si
on attend de lui qu'il fasse du 20 10
parce que ça ça c'est quelque chose qui
est ce qui était d'un profil d'élite
si c'est si on avait cette vision
polluants le drafter peut-être plus haut
mais je pense que non je pense que ça va
plus ça va prendre du temps ci ou pour
qu'on installe avec des tués à tout
maintenant on disait derrière la mêlée
ça peut prendre du temps aussi et puis
très disert à ça va prendre du temps
peut-être jean moreau on disait
peut-être que ça peut prendre du temps
parce que il ya la transition avant
terme de niveau pour chaque bonne taille
a des arguments qui font que ça pourrait
prendre du temps que ça soit le niveau
de compétition affronter la physicalité
de leurs joueurs manquantes ou des
choses comme ça mais j'ai l'impression
que ça va de mieux en mieux donc je
pense que je pense qu'il peut joueur une
billet dès l'an prochain
sharif a donc la capacité à battre son
homme et le tir qui en question papara
par rapport à ce que tu disais alan sur
les critères ben tu as qui sur ton
deuxième panier du coup puisque lui n'y
est pas j'ai trois noms j'ai géré une
seconde j'ai skalli burns parce que je
crois que ce que tu es barnes et devrait
être utilisé comme créateur primaires
sont absolument n'importe quel allein
option venant de syrie l'efficacité est
le nom le plus controversé de mon de mon
big boy david jost d'idées grâce à des
ponts l'ellipse terraine bien moi j'aime
pas trop je comprends pourquoi j'aime
pas trop mais je crois que je crois que
c'est un joueur qui va montrer junique
puis une des spécificités
je trouve absolument fascinante chez
josh guider c'est que ces lectures sont
tellement rapides et les cépages sont
tellement véloce et précise qu'il n'a
absolument pas besoin de battre son
homme pour trouver pour trouver sa cible
à la base il peut rester derrière son
homme absolument confortablement ont peu
reculé mais mais frappé sa cible à la
poste il est bon comme ça et pour ça je
crois vraiment que c'est un joueur qui
conquit contournent ces limitations
physiques et ses limitations physiques
elles ne peuvent que ça même si c'est
intéressant on parlera plus en détail de
josh qui dit donc sur les trois noms que
tu as cité
on a quand même deux mecs qui savent pas
trop shooter c'est ça ouais ouais
pourquoi ils sont pourquoi ils sont un
cran en dessous de christianisme donne
en fait pour expliquer aux personnes je
dirais que physiquement
josh guidé ses pas du tout dans la même
ligue que kate collègues amis la
difficulté à se rendre à la noë il a des
difficultés à se vendre comme une comme
une menace à la non aussi saucier qui
est vraiment ce qui est vraiment un
problème et je crois qu'il s'améliore
beaucoup en tant que chanteur je crois
que je crois qu'il a pris un niveau
supérieur cette année sa mécanique est
encore un peu étrange mais il n'y a pas
peur de tirer les propos de série donc
je crois qu'un
un shooting star en nba va être capable
de faire le ménage là-dedans comme un
maxi rapidement est ce que des bandes
c'est que c'est tellement un phénomène
physique
moi je sais pas trop quoi faire avec lui
jusqu'à pâques
tu me le donnent pour l'escale thing
nombreux postes écrit que je me suis tu
as pris plein de fautes et justement
c'est no mendy physique c'est le jouet à
typer commentaires de catch your turn it
on laisse absolument démolir le pauvre
bougre qui l'attend à ou un qui l'attend
certes les gros il est fort et non s'ils
ont des rasoirs qui à sa sortie de
collège je le vois très bien passé le
test du wallaby dans la mode et ce qui
la hisse qu'il a les variations jeu de
rythme puisqu'il n'est pas il est pas
très rapide n'est pas loin non plus ce
qui là les variations de rythme et le la
dextérité suffisante dans le dribble
puisque là on l'a on va parler de
technique aussi dans tout ce dont 10 de
tous tous les joueurs dont on parle
depuis le début par non le dribble est
absolument indispensable à tout ce
qu'ils doivent faire donc est-ce que je
scotty bande à ça c'est un work in
progress c'est un travail je faisais que
le contrôle du ballon et la sécurité du
ballon moi ça me va côté créativité du
dribble pas encore d'un joueur qui voit
quand même à sa droite mettant qui peut
protéger le ballon
- symbole moi c'est un peu pourquoi
ça va être ça va être que je disais il
ya aucune équipe qui va jouer de manière
conventionnelle avec cathy marines comme
meneur comme meneur de jeu comme
créateur mais je crois pas que séduit
non plus je crois que c'est un joueur
qui va pas y revenir
les autres vous avez
manu alan vous avez scotty barnes en
tant que bolton l'heure ou pas oui oui
chez manu mais en 2d à bollène leur
secondaire c'est à dire qui va pas
forcément initié la première action mais
un peu dans le corps une fois je
comprends vraiment très habile dans le
moule dans le moule de kybele tu le ver
est dans le moule de qui dans le rôle de
qui plutôt que ce qui est dans le moule
c'est compliqué il un profil particulier
mais dans le genre en termes de rôle je
crois pas qu'il a un rôle vraiment ces
stéréotypes dans lequel on peut rentrer
parce que c'est un joueur qui est
tellement unique qui tellement étrange
mais je savais plus comment les
caméléons avaient organisé leur attaque
au tour de lebron james qui rentrait de
pétrole à répétition et quelques années
moi j'ai l'impression que si on met
scotty bowman en un contre un compte à
peu près n'importe quel défenseur au
siècle justement il est tellement long
il est tellement fort il est lorsqu'il
fera un erre d'aller
quand je vois qu'ils d'explosifs dans
des petits dans des petits espaces mais
ce qui prend un nadal et comme s'ils
peuvent faire je crois que c'est
extrêmement déçu par alain autres donc
je m'organise c'est pour toi
l'optimisation ultime de scotty bande je
vois c'est un peu le catch les cases
poignée tous un peu le
le problème est que ce type on sait je
crois que si t'es pas grave quand ils
utilisent comme ça où tu peux c'est un
joueur à fort contexte comme
comme sharif l'est aussi on en parlait
tout à l'heure
alan tu as dit non sur scotty barnes non
parce que c'est ce que tu bornes c'est
mon administrateur principal avec 4
shooteur autour ça peut marcher mais
j'ai une mauvaise attaque donc ça ne
m'intéresse pas il sera probable c'est
une mauvaise attaque parce que il là
j'aurais pas une attaque et une dans un
des dix meilleures offensives racing de
la ligue je pense je pense que passe
parce que les défenseurs s'ajusteront
passeront en dessous et déjà trouvé 4
shooteur élite
c'est dur mais ne pas avoir la menace du
poulpe sur ton initiateurs principal
c'est que ton attaque elle et elle va
être rapide qu'en saison régulière ça
peut passer mais je pense que ce serait
une sorte de gianni sans le monstruosité
physique
voilà c'est ça et et le contexte mignot
qui est très bon le projet parce que
dire sur porto mais ce quotidien ce
n'est pas janis et si on veut le faire
jouer comme janis igor anton attaque
sera pas au rendez vous ces pme pourtant
je suis très haut sur ce petit noir 9
surprise les dix jeux de retrait devant
d'y aller une seconde donc je les
quatrièmes de mon big board est pour moi
là où il doit être utilisé c'est en web
creator secondaires plutôt tertiaire
défenseur capable de switcher 1 à 5
c'est pour ça en fait j'étais revoir son
fibre à 8 19 ou en fait ils jouaient que
avec des stars évoqué avec qui jouer
avec kane je pense qu'en fait le
contexte florida state
il était très précis et je pense que ça
sera le seul contexte de l'histoire chat
de scotty bornes ce sera dans ce
contexte là à monde verde il était avec
kate bonbons de toutes façons c'était
pas lui qui avait la balle en corner
avant le vernis ouais il était peut-être
un peu trop jeune pour projeter tu vois
dans ce qu'est ce que c'est parce que ça
arrivera avec team usa et sortait du le
sde u19 il sortait du banc et jouer avec
une jane green et kiraly oui c'est tout
ça c'était pas lui l'initiateur vente
principal et il était super fort dans ce
rôle de parent et initiateur secondaire
avorté resserre
toujours la bonne passe toujours la
bonne coupe toujours les mains active en
transition s'est bien se placer joueur
d'équipé vraiment google parfait d'une
top équipe et moi j'y crois énormément
parce que je pense que si le tir suit il
pourrait être il pourrait être plus site
web être peut-être ce que dit ben
mais pour l'instant vu qu'il n'a pas le
tir je peux pas le mettre dans la
catégorie des bollène l'heure ce qui
n'empêche que je doive quand même très
haut manu tu as qui dans ton deuxième
panier au buzzer
je suis monsieur man ok donc johnson
on en a parlé aussi dans un podcast donc
vous pouvez y aller en détail simplement
le meneur de gonzaga excellent
gestionnaire
pourquoi un cran en dessous de caïds
poser une question cubaine
pour moi il lui manque encore de la ce
que ce que cahill a déjà ses de la
régularité dans ses passes la régularité
dans cet effet il fait super beau coup
de filet un peu trop fou fou il perd un
peu trop de ballons et c'est vraiment ça
qu'il faut qu'il arrive à asté peuple
mais moi je le vois plus en secondaires
importants
initiateur secondaire plus à un joueur
capable de te prouver de la bonne passe
mais surtout capable d'attaquer le
panier à à fond les ballons quoi ouais
ouais je vois très bien d'accord avec
toi et tu m'as dit très mal très mal
très mal alors intéressant on n'a jamais
parlé vase il dit nous qui est très mal
meneur de flo rida qu'à deux saisons
dans les jambes ses capacités
incroyables à créer son espace pour qui
pour son tir s'est rarement ça pour moi
sa principale force un visionnaire
passeur encore assez moyen mais il ya
des choses à rater et assez je trouve
aussi un de rated en défense il s'est
rarement que je pense qu'il va être
capable de le surprendre en nba mais
c'est surtout sa capacité à créer
l'espace qui est incroyable il est
capable de le faire partout sur le
terrain et ça si vous est alors ces
jeunes activistes que ça oui là il est
de la même année que beaucoup de braves
tête
enfin beaucoup de freshman était très
jeune en est fier oui il va pas si vite
que ça ans manu c'est pas j'arrive
cooper dont on parle est inférieur non
mais moi j'ai eu
j'ai envie d'y croire que j'aime
beaucoup comme son copain scotty lewis
mais sa seule chose voilà de floride a
aussi mais qui n'est pas du tout un un
porteur de ballon à l'année dans ton
deuxième tiers de l'initiateur en fait
tu as dit penser mais dans mon deuxième
tiers il ya déjà une green tout seul
parce que pour moi il initiera
d'attaquants nba il initiera
d'attaquants une vieille le faisait déjà
un peu angélique il le faisait à
prolifique prep en high school
il a tout le temps initiés de la taxe
aux flobarts people19 encore qu'est pour
pourquoi pourquoi moins que pourquoi
encre en dessous des idées pourquoi un
cran au dessus des autres c'est ça alors
un cran en dessous de kate parce que en
termes encore de crasson pour les hôtels
lecture avancée lecture sur pick'n roll
ça il n'est pas au niveau de quelques
nine gamme mais en terme de coût de
poules hop et de dac et de capacité à se
créer aussi son espace et son tir et il
est très très fort donc ils les airs en
dessous de kate parce que la création
pour les autres elle n'est pas encore
très très bonne il est au dessus
dingue que dans un groupe de cinq
joueurs que j'ai parce que physiquement
en termes d'explosivité
c'est un athlète pour moi au dessus au
dessus des 5 autres en fait c'est pour 6
alors les simples donc les 5 c'est james
goodnight challenger charef cooper très
man jazz guider et je voulais mettre
kamto masse mais je ne peux pas le
maître des requêtes qui auraient des
initiateurs malraux oui parce qu'il pose
pas beaucoup la balle au sol ses shoots
mais je pense qu'il peut le faire
il pourrait pourtant la demande c'est
vrai que c'est un peu un mystère
cameron thomas sous forêts faire un
podcast sur alors il ya plusieurs choses
qui m'interroge
la première c'est que c'est pas du tout
les mêmes profils les uns avec les
autres et la première c'est james
goodnight toi tu pense qu'on va lui
donner le ballon et qu'on va lui dire
vas-y attaque ça va être efficacement je
pense que c'est possible c'est parce que
c'est pas parce qu'il l'a je pense que
c'est pas parce qu'il n'a pas fait yukon
qui peut pas le faire et surtout besoin
de son de son scoring parce que sans lui
en termes offensifs l'équipe ne mettait
pas de points donc on est tous mené
surtout voilà tu es un peu le finisseur
mais j'ai trouvé vraiment par séquences
et voilà c'est un risque que je tente
une pièce que je lance mais je pense que
james goodnight peu unis c'est le
d'attac
en fait on une bille et je pense
vraiment qu'il peut le faire parce qu'il
a il alarmes des couleurs en fait et
comme ils alarmes du spoiler sa pauvre à
je pense ouvrir beaucoup de choses dans
son jeu et qu'après un coach et un staff
pourra faire améliorer tout ce qu'est
lecture et tout ce qui est compréhension
de défense adverse nous a dans un
premier rôle dans un second rôle manu
parlais tout à l'heure
très bien du rôle qu'il voyait pour
receuillir +12 comme on disait avant
deuxième arrière tu vois kate et john
green peuvent être premier initiateur
d'une équipe nba tous les autres pour
moi non avec l'exception sharif parce
que pour moi je le dis mais charef
cooper s'il n'est pas ton initiateurs
principal sur le terrain ça peut poser
problème parce qu'en terme de gmac un
disque à la bbc donc le rôle que tu as
quoi tu sers si t'as pas la balle en
gros et bien c'est très problématique
donc je ménage de mettre dans le groupe
parce que j enregistrais parce que vous
aimez
en fait seul debout knight man et guider
l'utilisateur secondaire ou alors
initiateurs principal avec le banc pour
recommencer
ok est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec
cette affirmation
et ça c'est déjà très intéressant c'est
à dire seuls deux joueurs alors ben t'as
déjà dit que tu étais pas d'accord
puisque tard ajouté scotty barnes mais
seuls deux joueurs peuvent être des
initiateurs principaux efficace je
complète en nba
selon alan manu
moi je vois pas le challenge initié
quelque chose enfin c'est pile et pas
dans ma définition en fait de du
l'initiateur ouais donc pour toi il ya
que quelques juste posé une question à
mme agnew pas non est-ce que brown et
bill donovan messieurs les zac
lavillénie site d'attac principalement
une pied maintenant vous aidant super
truc jane green peut devenir sa non
inscrits ce modèle hockey n'a pas s'il
ya trop de carences dans la voix pour
moi il a trop de carences dans la vie
dans la compréhension la vision la pl
passe voilà si un attaquant et des
carences et vaclav henin s'est lui
déclaré roseann pour ma part kevin rudd
qui est un baume initiateurs aux spurs
cette année esquerdes initiateurs séméac
la médaille au ciel elle initie rien du
tout et paris à minnesota mine
maintenant enfin même maintenant je sais
pas ouais moi je suis pas enfin je viens
pas trop les boules il a progressé mais
s'épanouit voilà tu sais ben pour moi
c'est un second derrière pour mazak la
ligne
tmardi rosen site pareil on peut les
problèmes ici mais à go on en parlait
moi c'est les deux initiateurs croise
paul leur équipe après ces deux équipes
qui sont pas qualifiés pour les
play-offs qu'il faut le dire mais c'est
quand même deux initiateurs primaire de
leur équipe alors tout mais je peux tu
quantifie un mec comme ça cadeaux de
qualité en fait il pourrait être bien
meilleur si on l'utilisé pas of the ball
mais en deuxième arrière capable
d'attaquer tout faire sauter pas soit
parce que oui mais c'est peut-être plus
une divergence de
compréhension de l'édifice rôle oui de
définition que vous avez puisque dit la
même chose mais mais juste toi manu pour
toi cette il doit d'abord faire une
passe quelqu'un qui a le ballon alors
que c'est pas forcément local pour moi
il terminé comment ces mini site à une
attaque il y termine ouais ouais
oui oui mais c'est vrai que ça dépend du
contexte en saison régulière un peu
moins mais en playoffs aujourd'hui tu
vois tous ceux qui ont le ballon dans
les grands moments sont des personnes
qui peuvent faire rentrer le ballon dans
le panier
pour faire très très jeune mais bon là
c'est on parle du très haut niveau en
playoffs évidemment et la majorité de la
saison régulière n'est pas comme ça à
notre grand désespoir d'ailleurs
j'ai demandé à tout le monde le tiers de
demandes être devin pour alan c'est le
tir 3 pardon parlons de josh qui dit
mais manu tu l'as vu ou pas je pas de
piéger là dessus tu l'as vu un peu
beaucoup passionnément
j'ai vu des mouvements de match en fait
d'écran des grands à la toile mais je me
suis pas intéressé trop mais de ce que
j'ai vu je pense à dire à un joueur de
n3 mois déjà il a une dégaine ouais moi
je pense qu'il y là j'avoue j'ai un peu
fait du délit de faciès
après il sort des passagers ou fin par
soi mais bien sûr ah bah oui si vous
regardez gamme de facteurs de grands
facteurs puisqu'ils grand mais ben est
ce que tu peux nous décrire rapidement
le job guide y en a je crois jamais
parlé alors qu'il pourrait partir
lottery pick donc il faudrait il les
temps bah ouais moi j'ai bien fois un
job qu'il angels québec qui pourrait
passer en top 10
c'est un meneur de jeu slash ailier on
sait pas trop quelle position il joue un
peu à la can am see suite je crois même
si ce refus en plus pas encore 200
livres il a vraiment faire un physique
crée un athlétique il joue c'est un
cheikh bass pro sky cse l'initiateur il
crée pour les autres il n'a pas
l'instinct de créer pour lui même si un
des passages les plus spectaculaires à
une biya je crois qu'il l'a repris et le
repris le flambeau de la mélo balle pour
passoire le plus spectaculaire elle
exagère tellement haut mais non mais non
à côte on peut on peut lui reprocher
beaucoup de choses à jaws guider mais
pour le spectaculaire dépasse là il se
rappelle de la meinau pour dire ça oui
oui oui oui il va revenir
je vais faire une comparaison musicale
vas-y vas-y parme
non mais je te dis pas que je ne dis pas
qu'il est au niveau de la mêlée au bol
mais se dit qu'il a repris le flambeau
c'est lui c'est lui le français est plus
spectaculaire à une bière cette année
mais mais c'est ça c'est un joueur qui a
grandi encore qui a encore des problèmes
de coordination parce que justement il
est temps de grandir son corps change il
est en train de se jouer avec des hommes
depuis plus d'un an je crois les il
apprend à synchroniser son shoot à un
niveau professionnel et il y en a vu
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de progrès
cette année
mon plus gros mon plus gros construit
avec lui mon plus gros problème c'est
qu'elle a beaucoup de difficulté à se
vendre comme étant une menace lorsqu'il
va le cercle ce à dire que les gens ont
très peu sérieux les gens ils viennent
ils viennent le le forcer à faire des
passes ou forcer à faire des mauvais jeu
défensivement aussi c'est un certain
problème parce qu'il peut pas tous les
efforts qui devraient faire sur le
terrain c'est un joueur qui fuyait joué
particulièrement défensivement ça ça va
causer problème un billet mais juste le
faire qui soit un meneur de jeu aussi
gras tous les possibilités pour lui de
devenir un joueur d'impact sont vraiment
sont vraiment là ils vont
je veux dire on lui donne un jeu au
poste bas il va il va chouchouter par
dessus à peu près n'importe et qui
volent défendra sa position
on lui on lui donner mais ce match va
être capable de jouer le match
défensivement pouvoir je crois le cachet
sur le moins bons joueurs offensivement
où le deuxième il ya quelque chose les
quelque chose avec jaws l'idée qui fait
en sorte que si c'est un projet dans le
primaire il ya quelque chose à faire
avec son ton était donné pour la
potentielle des îles palau présentement
mais il s'en vend projet c'est vrai et
ce qui peut être autre chose qu'un beau
l'aisne l'eure
je ne crois pas je crois qu'elles sont
son attrait principal c'est sa capacité
à voir le terrain d'ici peu à prendre
des décisions rapides bien anticipé le
jeu je crois que c'est beaucoup plus
élevé que la plupart des joueurs dans
cette graphie si je crois même que
comptait créativité côté anticipation
c'est pas du même meilleur que quelqu'un
les gammes mais je vais y a pas le
physique qui suivent je le faisais quoi
être un problème pour une haleine qu'est
ce que tu penses de josh pour compléter
ce qu'a dit ben se sont redit il peut
être d'autres choses qui ont pour les
initiateurs comme tu l'as dit simplement
six tirs mais c'est pour l'instant ils
tirent pas donc acheté josh guider dans
une pluralité drôle c'est acheter le tir
tout simplement mais je pense que oui un
peu comme benny hill sera rien que par
son plein et king et sa taille il sera
toujours utile sur un terrain en fait je
pense sera toujours il servira toujours
à quelque chose et encore une fois c'est
pas parce qu'on n'a pas vu beaucoup plus
soft ball ou qui sait pas le faire voilà
on a eu le contexte nba
adélaïde et une ambiance adélaïde césar
les seuls des 36 tistics et après ça ils
ont mis en avant parce que c'est parce
que c'était la coqueluche du du
programme nba de cette année ils ont à
jouer dans un rôle assez précis je pense
tu as le plus de matchs que moi c'était
souvent le même rôle c'était bolender
créateurs pour les autres il est jeune
comme l'a dit mais n'est-ce pas parce
qu'il a fait tout ça cette année qui
veut peut-être pas faire un truc
différent
donc on pourrait parier là-dessus mais
ça passera par un tir je pense qu'il
sera à la mêlée au bol et pourcentage
soutien n'était pas bon mais je pense
qu'on pouvait tous eu trois dire que son
tir avec beaucoup plus confiance que je
suis john ging vous pour tout ce qui est
mécanique ou d'autre chose ça va être le
tir qui va un peu changer ta là le futur
de guider en nba je pense plus que dos
et ça pour tout le monde en réalité j'ai
l'impression qu'on a dit ça pour tout le
monde mais pour lui c'est un peu le cas
devient risqué à ce moment-là de la
drave de toute façon philosophiquement
ben plus on descend plus c'est risqué de
choisir quelqu'un qui est porteur de
balle pour être porteur de balle puisque
puisque ça veut dire que l'on a on va
lui donner des responsabilités alors que
l'île est pas dans le premier panier
ben oui puis comme dirait moi je
sélectionne pas un porteur de balle
passait le premier tour puis mais pour
un jeu jeudi des je trouve que ce
appareil faso tu peux avoir une espèce
de polyvalence positionnelle je pense
que vous rappelez de s'appelle josh
mcroberts la nba ouais on lui mettait
déjà de découvrir un jour oui y sommes
guidés avrillé peut-être impose de plus
de plus grand qu'une idée mais lorsqu'on
découvre ou est ce qu'on le mettait hors
de la raquette
il était reproché à votre vision
absolument extraordinaire je crois que
des planches et josh guider pour être
utilisé comme ça une bille c'est à dire
comme un espèce de stretch 4 mais
vraiment à mi-distance je crois qu'il
est vraiment un plancher jeudi je crois
que comme dit à l'amf aurait porte
qu'est ce qui arrive sur les meetings et
sata répond en sorte votre jour et eux
très bien passons puisque le theule
heures l'heure tourne
manu passons à tonton panier d'après on
va arriver petit à petit vers la fin du
premier tour j'imagine on s'arrêtera là
qu'est ce que tu as quel est ton panier
d'après de bollène leur primaire au
secondaire
donc j'ai que des secondaires a pour moi
c'est jason springer des viandes
mitchell et rogatien cobit ce très bien
ça
donc on a déjà parlé de john mitchell
dans le podcast sur baylor c'est un des
trois arrières de cette équipe de baylor
qui a remporté le titre cette année des
vieilles mitchell étant sans aucun doute
le plus explosif détroit il a été
excellent au shoot sur une saison
peut-il être plus sur plusieurs saisons
c'est un pot de colle défensif
peut-il défendre autre chose que des
arrières voilà à peu près les questions
je vous ai résumé les grandes lignes du
profil des viennes mitchell juste pour
finir sur lui ben et alan est ce qu'il
est dans votre tir suivant où aller on a
remonté à 3 pour moi et allan a dit non
je crois non non alan je crois que tu
l'as bien bas l'ami des viennes mitchell
on parlera plus en détail dans un autre
podcasts ou alors si tu le fais en deux
phrases on peut le faire mais trop petit
66% lancers-francs carrière 23 en
septembre
ça m'intéresse pour au premier tour très
bien manu parle-moi de jayden springer
tennessee donc porteur de ballon
secondaires donc un peu le rôle que tu
envisageais pour dja lenssens tout à
l'heure quelles sont les qualités qu'il
a qui peut le lui faire espérer ce rôle
selon toi
bastien un gars qui sait pour moi c'est
mon avis qui sait vraiment quasiment
tout faire mes moyens bien et donc du
coup il ya encore un une marge de
progression pour moi elle est infime
pour moi il sait quasiment déjà un
produit fini mais il ya comme quelque
chose à une cinquième vitesse à faire
passer et je suis vraiment dans les
passes il a une vision assez ces deux
packs forcément flashy ce qui fait mais
c'est très bien il est toujours la bonne
réaction de la bonne passe croyais quand
ils voient une action qui me revient en
tête je suis plus conductrice était où
il est tête de raquette et deux joueurs
qui arrivait vers lui il appelle les
joueurs ont fait 1 par la passe était
panier de points termine et c'est
vraiment ça qui me qui me fait dire
qu'il peut être un secondaire un
initiateur secondaire si on est un
grossiste il est au niveau du tir faut
vraiment qu'ils arrivent à développer un
tir efficace et combler ceux qui
deviennent encore plus efficace et à la
passe dans cette vision du jeu est là
pour ce sera un bonbon ils étaient sûrs
efficaces sur faible volume cette année
aux shoots puisqu'on à 80 % aux lancers
francs et 43 à 3 points mais il en
prenait que deux par match donc c'est
pas le plus représentatif et est donc
juste pour ceux qui n'ont pas le site
sous les yeux un 93 93 kg de 10
d'envergure jean masson whip il est
solide sur les appuis le garçon
visiblement il avait des problèmes à la
cheville
toute la saison et est désormais ça va
mieux et donc il arrive à montrer autre
chose je sais plus j'ai lu ça dans les
dents les work out qu'il fait à droite à
gauche donc son nom commence il est 14e
sur notre big board
mais il ya une grande disparité de
classement à l'année ce qu'il est dans
ton tiers suivant en fait je n'ai pas
pas vus comme bollène l'heure mais s'il
l'était il serait dans le tiers avec
ceux qui se moquent night cooper man et
guider ou que tu veux vraiment des gens
qui y vont au cercle pour
et qui vont être efficace en tant que
première option mais franchement son
protégé revue quelques matches où l'on
discuté ensemble cet après midi fait
qu'ils soient si jeune si intéressant
est que l'envergure hic qu'il est wac
qui est pour moi été mal utilisée a été
initiée donc que je pense qu'il ya
vraiment mieux à faire avec lui mais je
veux dire que le matériau d hyper
intéressant pour donc je pense que je
dois ferait il serait tirs 3 24 ans très
bien
ben tu m'as dit cui 1 il est là pour toi
aussi tu n'as pas dit oui j'aime
beaucoup beaucoup d'expérience je crois
que c'est un joueur je vais je vais
aborder la même sens que manu mais
partiellement c'est à dire qu'on sait
déjà qu'il est comme joueur je prends ta
marge de progression est campé plus
grande puisque manu prétend mais on sait
qu'il est comme joueur puis il va il
vaut vraiment si j'osais on sait
pourquoi on le draft dans le fond mais
oui oui c'est un symbole 1re secondaire
pour moi dans la plus pure tradition du
terme
c'est pas en jouant qu'une vision ronde
jour incroyable mais ce joie qui est
une vision de jeu qui bien une et que
lui je vois jamais faire des passes qui
sont communes
il prend toujours des décisions
rapidement mais il prend les bonnes
décisions mais qui surprennent qui
souffrent parfois ses coéquipiers je
suis pas sûr à quel point j achète le
tire bouchon un peu david wheater à mon
goût mais aussi défensivement on parle
d'une brute sanguinaire
il est incroyable l'ancien un peu
comment jeudi une brute sanguinaire et
silencieuse parce qu'autant parlait dé
vienne mitchell qui est vraiment y colle
aux shorts donc on à l'heureux qui va
tuer son adversaire direct au top
springer c'est juste qu'il est tout en
bois constrictor exactement il est
vraiment très très léger sur ses appuis
toujours à toujours en équilibre
puis c'est ça que tu deviens tu dribbles
et par le ballon le ballon et par email
donc moi je trouve moi je vois je ne
compare pas directement joueurs allaient
pas dire que je sois par jour je vois
une qualité match mike jones gagnant je
vois une possibilité d'évoluer dans un
rôle similaire et demi je sais il va
peut-être pas la qualité de marc smaele
mais je crois qu'il est mêlé c'est très
intéressant j'ai jamais entendu cette
comparaison je la trouve intéressante
qui d'autre tu as
ben non en tir suivant avec j'ai très
mal compte de qui on a déjà parlé et
j'ai une charrette butler donc l'autre
de baylor voilà qui visiblement des
pépins physiques mais bon nous on sait
pas pour sûr donc pour l'instant tu l'as
pas changé ton classement sur lui mais
n'ont pas pour l'instant ce que j'ai
entendu parler c'est que c'était une
malformation car il y aurait été
diagnostiqué lorsqu'il a été recruté à b
le mec donc les équipes d'un ennemi
ignorer je sais pas qu'est ce que ça
veut dire pour lui mais en termes de
d'initiateur secondaire john butler et
répond un peu à toutes les demandes nbc
schutter absolument extraordinaire c'est
un gars qui sait jouer au basket ce que
tu es au qi basket il apporte une vision
incroyable il fait toujours il a
toujours la bonne lecture de jeu une
traîtresse d'éduquer le seul problème ce
petit avec john battle 6.3 physique
si un joueur explose un peu le contact
lorsque sa devenu difficile
c'est un joueur qui défensivement
parlant ce peu bousculé beaucoup donc
ses initiateurs secondaire mais je
n'arrête pas de le dire si dieu si dieu
le veut son physique son car elle lui
permet d'être drafté en billets moi je
pense qu'il va vous fouillez en paca
blanche les yeux dans une équipe
manu pour finir sur ton frontières tu
nous a pas parlé de jock by this ce qui
est intéressante elle seule d'entre nous
à l'avoir au premier tour peut-être
canico aussi mais non je pense pas
roccat ce jocou by this donc dont on
parlait déjà l'année dernière et qui est
un meneur lituanien qui mesure 1,93 donc
comme jayden springer et qui est un
meneur qui est voilà qui vient bien de
son pays en fait puisque il sait à peu
près tout
le l'ubs et les images que j'ai regardé
donc tsonga déjà pour présenter vite
fait gaucher qui y voient elles
guérissent chaos menace ou qui a déjà
plusieurs saisons en championnat
lituanien et aussi surtout deux saisons
d'euroligue dans les jambes donc habitué
à jouer contre des sacré bonhomme en
face de lui et c'est vraiment un joueur
qui sous contrôle qui ait jamais en
panique toujours ok voilà c'est un genre
assez génial à voir je trouve et qui
pour une seconde initiateurs c'est en
fait il n'est pas encore parfait dans
dans ses choix non serbes dans les
termes de vision tout ça mais c'est
vraiment un gars comme beaucoup se
trouvent deux flashs intéressant chez
lui après la lettre difficulté c'est
qu'il est dans une équipe qui est quand
même assez cadré
donc il répondait sur un sur le terrain
il suivait vraiment les schémas
techniques tactiques
donc c'est un peu difficile de savoir
comment le prolonger et ce qu'on le
garde comme un joueur comme ça qui va
être dans un rôle vraiment précis dans
une équipe cadrés ou est ce qu'on peut
lui faire confiance
c'est ça que je veux voir moi est ce que
si on lui donne la balle s'il est
vraiment une option des trois premières
options offensives d'une équipe est ce
qu'il va pouvoir faire gagner son équipe
et faire stepped up ses coéquipiers
peut-être un joueur de banc s'il vend
une billets sachant qu'il est en
discussion avec barcelone visiblement
huawei il aurait quelques contacts sur
bas il a connu jacky vitus qui était son
coach assas guiry ceci donc le lien et
on peut faire par là je crois que c'est
une discussion tout contrat 3,1 me
semble donc avoir il a encore son nom à
la draft pour le moment qu'à voir ce qui
se passe dans les prochaines semaines
prochains jours même intéressant donc de
mettre occasion cobit ce qui n'a pas
encore 21 ans donc et quand même pas
vieux pourtant ce fait longtemps qu'on
en parle
al antaki danton tiers suivant et on
finira avec ça alors j'arrête butler
nation'' island friends bryan berg et
puis david mitchell parce que je le mets
fins sans fin mais je le mets un peu
dans un pack ouais ok alors
brent bloomberg on a fait une longue
interview avec lui
il s'est effectivement joué un pick and
roll temps qu'il faut aller à droite oui
encore au surtout un très bon surtout un
très bon shooteur mais moi je l'est en
fin de premier tour aussi je trouve
qu'il est assez sous côtés mais
d'ailleurs il en train de faire des
work-outs et il en a si john les états
unis il les enchaîne
ifs il mesure quand même 2 10 ce qui
n'est pas rien à dire quand on parle de
ouais quand on parle d'initiateur le
monsieur fait de 10 donc c'est assez
rare d'avoir des gens de son wendel donc
j'imagine ce pour ça que tu l'as moulins
parce que peut-être il est passé shooter
de 10 et c'est aux primaires mais
secondaire de vraiment potentiellement
pourquoi j'étais très impressionné par
ce que j'ai vu en eurocoupe je pensais
vraiment pas que c'était ce type de
vente et tu as nationale en national en
aval a alors nationale landes c'est pour
le coup un scoreur ouais c'est un pur
score
c'est un des shooteurs en sortie de
dribble et plus fort de la cuve et je
pense les plus forts du championnat
initié cette année c'est un chouchou
avec ben on aime bien gvt
on en avait parlé même avant la saison
on avait dit voilà ce gars faut le
suivre parce que c'est un gros gros ce
coureur et dans les matchs que j'ai pu
voir donc peu de matches de vie si ou en
intégralité malheureusement mais il ya
quelques indices pourquoi pas d'un début
de jeu de pick and roll en fait donc
peut-être un initiateur en sortie de
banc vous roux deuxième initiateur 2
avec un gros gros combos guarda ses
côtés ça peut le faire
je prends le risque parce qu'au bout
d'un moment sa capacité à tirer en poule
appel fait que sa pauvre beaucoup
beaucoup de choses dans son jeu un peu
comme bouc night ans alitée donc
personne
ne me parle de de josh christopher de
prendre de boston 2 0 il ya mousse non
pas pour moi rockhopper cassine retail
pour moi mais solide un niveau en
dessous a permis deux absolument mais ce
sont des joueurs qui en tout cas au
niveau où il jouait cette année
''je allen johnson aussi friends bonheur
un peu
et ouais parfois le ballon en main
personne n'a parlé de johnatan kumming à
ça c'est quand même super quand on sorte
a dit ce que je sais c'est problématique
quand on voit son tir oui mais je veux
dire c'est que c'est comme ça qui va
être drafté oui pour être pour être un
initiateur je pense c'est pas la bonne
solution mais à voir oui c'est peut être
pour la bonne idée mais après tout les
jours que tu as cité si on les a quand
même je pense tous quasiment au premier
tour mais c'était parce que là on
parlait de rôle comme très bien sûr non
et bien sûr mais c'était pas une
critique c'était pour pour
contextualiser pour les personnes qui
nous écoutent
est-ce que vous avez une wild card en
second tour puisque je l' ai dit tout à
l'heure on parlait de la draft 2018
il y avait quand même voilà alors on est
d'accord ou pas d'accord mais dit
anthony melton parfois il porte un peu
le ballon très c'est un très bon joueur
et demi les mectons diane tony melton
j'ai cité qui d'autre y avait
il y avait déjà une bronson
il y avait bondi 21 grams là pour le
coup y'a vraiment explosé et el cheikh
mme hilton jack layton qui apporte qui
porte le ballon sur certaines
possessions en playoffs pour
philadelphie donc c'est des choses qui
arrivent
alors c'est pas des fleurs des
initiateurs on va dire au long cours
mais ils peuvent le faire pendant
pendant un match
est-ce que vous avez une wild card une
carte libre sauvage
marcus des gars aussi marcuse égard aux
skis joueurs de creighton
pour alan manuels couture
moi je mettrais jolie yayi et miles
mcbride hockey ait mcbride pas mal parce
que parce qu'effectivement il gros
défenseur sur les postes 1 2 et est
assez explosif peut se créer sentir il
est d'ailleurs à la limite du 1er tour
sur notre billboard il ya un numéro 33
et toi tu la pile 33 maires et et ben
azzouz mcbride et le petit gars de
montréal cuisse droite et origan à wave
apart away avec la balle en ligne seront
tondues au secondaire slash tertiaire
moi j'y crois
d'accord alors ces enfants sont au
collège dit oui sans domingo allez moi
je vais mettre à l'expérience il te
plait juste de rajouter où on se fout
oui jac orie makhoul mclaughlin
ah voilà ça c'était pour pour les
méconnaissances le you'll see sans
t'avoir santa barbara en passant
d'oregon state
est-ce que tu l'ami mais tu l'aies mwin
le scouting report est disponible sur le
site d'air voilà réparé le garder ça
pour rien
et et moi je vais vous donner une petite
wild card je vous donnais dosunmu ou bon
ouais ouais mais bon il y défend il peut
porter la balle sur quelques dribbles il
va vite il a il a pas peur
c'est un leader il aime trop gagner pour
échouer ces matériaux oignies la main
antoine l'adorent toujours une petite
jour bon signe voilà c'était les
porteurs de ballon alors vous nous direz
si vous avez apprécié ou pas
l'expérience j'avoue qu'en tant
qu'animateur je savais pas trop comment
diriger les débats je savais pas trop si
banal année manu était préparé mais vous
nous ferez un retour mais en tout cas
c'était aussi pour parler d'eux un
paquet joueurs en même temps et essayer
de les classer donc comme ça vous avez
vu un petit peu la carte 7 de cette
draft se dessiner c'est ce qu'on essaye
de faire puisqu'il nous reste plus
beaucoup de temps avant la draft donc on
va parler également des des personnes
qui vont être plus considérés comme on
va trouver les autres rôles par porteur
de balle mais il y aller il ya ceux qui
posent les écrans il ya ceux qui qui
sont dans les coins je schématise
meilleur impose à décrire la grave c'est
bon le meilleur poseurs d'écran de la
draft ouais bon débat à voir il faut
aussi tout le monde sait que c'est des
recharges
voilà on va pouvoir y aller
messieurs il faudra qu'on parle de
cameron thomass j'ai pas d'un coup on va
le placer des fessées les fous furieux
des coûts avaient cessé merci merci à
vous d'avoir écouté
rendez vous sur envergure point c ou
rendez vous sur notre chaîne youtube
aussi avec la mode draft avec rémy
reverchon sur notre site il ya un
article qui vient de sortir sur nos
chouchous justement de la draft on a
également des autres articles qui vont
sortir et puis comme une dizaine
d'années scouting report à l'appel sur
envergure penser aux mains maintenant je
pense de plus de 60
donc ça fait beaucoup vous est de la
lecture et c'est assez détaillés pour
vous préparer pour le soir de la draft
même si votre équipe n'a qu'un choix en
42e position
on aura un autre jour voilà on aura
votre joueur pour vous en parler et vous
dire si une chance d'apporter aussi
selon nous une chance d'apporter quelque
chose à l'effectif de la franchise que
vous supportez merci encore une fois et
à bientôt sur envergure